divide y expresa el resultado como una
expresión racional simplificada indica
cuál es el dominio y entonces aquí
tenemos una expresión racional dividida
entre otra expresión racional y bueno
como hemos visto mucho últimamente estas
expresiones racionales se in determina
cuando el denominador es igual a 0 ok
entonces tenemos que p más 5 no puede
ser igual a 0 ya está pues no es una
igualdad pero podríamos decir que es una
desigualdad a esta desigualdad le
podemos sumar menos 5 de los dos lados y
entonces tenemos que menos 5 y menos
y aquí lo que nos queda es p 55 o sea
sólo una p que no puede ser igual a 0 +
menos 5 que es menos 5 y de la misma
forma para que esta otra expresión
racional no se determine esté bien
definida necesitamos que el denominador
sea distinto de 0 o sea necesitamos que
4 p más 20 sea distinto de 0
así es que pues estamos 20 de los dos
lados y nos queda 4 p tiene que ser
distinto de menos 20 y ahora dividimos
los dos lados entre 4 y nos queda que te
tiene que ser distinto de menos 20 entre
4 o sea menos 5 entonces si p es igual a
menos 5 estas dos expresiones racionales
se in determinan y si p es distinto de
menos 5 están muy bien determinadas
estas dos expresiones racionales así es
que ya podemos decir cuál es el dominio
do miño es igual al conjunto de todos
los números reales todos los números
reales
con todos los reales me refiero a todos
los números reales distintos de menos 5
bueno de hecho déjame escribirlo de otra
forma
todos los números reales
todos los números reales p tales que
tales
qué te es distinto de -5 y esto es un
conjunto muy bien ya indicamos cuál es
el dominio ahora ya sólo nos falta hacer
esta división y simplificar la respuesta
así es que pues hagamos la división
tenemos aquí una expresión racional y
estamos dividiendo la entre otra
expresión racional pero eso dividir
entre una expresión racional es
exactamente igual a multiplicar por el
inverso de esta expresión racional ok
multiplicar por el recíproco entonces
pues vamos a volver a escribirlo pero
ahora como una multiplicación tenemos
aquí dos temas 6
dos de más
/
5 y ahora dividimos entre esta expresión
racional pero como estábamos diciendo
eso es igual a multiplicar por su
recíproco o inverso
entonces estamos multiplicando por y el
recíproco o inverso de esta expresión
racional es 4 p más 20 entre 10 ok lo
que hice aquí fue cambiar la división
por multiplicación y voltear el
numerador y el denominador aunque ahí
nos queda así y bueno eso es igual
no quiero saltarme muchos pasos entonces
vamos a escribirlo todo para hacer esta
multiplicación de expresiones racionales
multiplicamos numerador por numerador y
entonces tenemos 2 p más
6 multiplicando a 4 p + 20
/ p + 5 por 10 ok ya hicimos esta
división entre expresiones racionales ya
nada más nos falta simplificar la pero
para simplificar la tenemos que sacar
todos los factores del numerador y del
denominador la factorización de este
término es 2 por p + 3
y de este término tenemos 4 por p 5
esta es la factorización de nuestro
numerador entonces vamos con el
denominador tenemos aquí
5 este ya no lo podemos factorizar más
entonces escribimos simplemente p
5 pero este 10 de aquí también lo
podemos factorizar podemos poner su
factorización en primos que es 2 por 5 y
ahora sí ya podemos empezar a eliminar
factores que estén en el numerador y en
el denominador pero que no se nos olvide
muy importante poner la restricción de
que no puede ser igual a menos 5 gray
que tiene que ser distinto de menos 5 y
ahora si con esta restricción este
objeto matemático es exactamente igual a
este otro objeto con todo y su
restricción entonces pues empecemos toda
la cancelada tenemos aquí x 2 y entre 2
que se cancela luego por aquí tenemos un
tema 5 en el numerador y en el
denominador
ahora podemos cancelar estos dos temas 5
porque tenemos la restricción de que
tiene que ser distinto de menos 5 y
entonces tema 5 ya no es igual a 0 y
entonces si lo podemos cancelar
simplemente nos queda 1
p más
por cuatro por cuatro entre cinco este
cinco de aquí que viene de el 10 y listo
pero otra vez no se nos vaya a olvidar
que me tiene que ser distinto de menos 5
y ahora si este objeto matemático
es exactamente igual a esta división
entre expresiones racionales